okay joining us now a man who has been
the executive director of the NFL
Players Association since 2009 he went
through one CBA negotiation in 2011
another one on the cusp of a union vote
voting is open at last until next
Thursday 11:59 p.m. Eastern the man is
de Morris Smith and D welcome back to
the program it's great to talk to you
Mike great to be here and always great
to talk to you okay so let's just get
right into it and I've been paying
attention to this process over the past
year or so for some people who really
don't have any interest in labor
negotiations it came as a surprise a few
weeks ago that everything seemed to be
close to a point where the union had a
proposal that he could officially
consider and go through the executive
committee and the board of player reps
and now we're at the point where there's
a vote by the rank-and-file walk me
through what kind of time effort and
calendar consumption was ultimately
devoted to the process where we now are
yeah well my great question and you know
I certainly understand that people you
know might look up one day and just
think that we air dropped into this but
this process dates back to even beyond
last year if you remember in 2017 I
challenged our player membership to
start getting ready for a potential work
stoppage the we knew that the deal ended
in March of 2021 and we have been
through one before so really the process
of thinking about the expiration of the
current deal started in 2017 in 2019 at
the last player rep meeting we had all
of the teams represented it was our
largest player rep meeting of all time
and we had all of our guys go through
three days of what are the most
significant issues to the players what
do we want to focus on one of the things
that came out of that meeting was a a
clear decision to focus on core players
and those guys are the guys who make up
the majority of the locker room they
probably are
superstars they may play somewhere
between three and six years but there
came out of that meeting in 2019 a list
of significant issues that we wanted to
address in a new collective bargaining
agreement a theme around core players
and then what came out of that in April
and May is a comprehensive proposal
created by the players that we sent to
management so in April or May of last
year that was the culmination of a
process not only to identify the issues
that were important to players but also
to respond to the league's overture that
they were interested in an early
collective bargaining agreement and and
just so we're clear the offer that the
NFL ultimately approved ratified
whatever a couple of weeks ago this
wasn't the first time you've heard back
from them there continued to be
negotiations and work and effort put
into this from the time you made your
first overture to them and the time we
got to the point where the league said
we're ready to go the CBA hinges now on
the union's vote oh absolutely
we made an O our proposal to the league
I want to say sometime in May we met
with the league shortly after that it
was probably somewhere around August
July where the league said that they
were not interested in doing an early
deal based on 16 games but they they
would consider an early deal based on a
17 game season along with our other you
know requests for improvements in the
collective bargaining agreement in fact
by the time that I started going on the
road in October it was clear from the
league that they would only consider a
deal in a 17 game proposal and we
actually made that
clear to all the teams all 32 teams that
we visited in those six to seven weeks
when I was on the road so you know to
say that this is somehow of a
abbreviated short-term instantaneous
process it has been a a legion of
meetings discussions conference calls
meetings with teams meeting with owners
staffs of staff meetings that have
literally gone on since May of last year
so Dee what would you say in response to
those who say now that the union's
position in response to the league's
essentially demand for 17 games we're
not doing 17 games we're negotiating
based on 16 games we're not going to
agree to 17 games and if you don't like
that basically lock us out in 2021 I
mean that's a comfortable position but
you know my job as a union leader my job
as a as a CEO of of the Union and making
an analysis about is this the right time
to engage in negotiations what are the
potential economic upsides and I don't
need to explain to you the importance of
the television contracts but as a union
leader
I'm constitutionally bound to negotiate
in good faith to rely on the information
that came from the board in 2019 to
discuss a proposal to bring that back to
our players to have them discuss it and
ultimately I don't get a vote on what
the deal is but I am constitutionally
obligated to to try to negotiate and put
together the best package and then
present that to our leadership to vote
on and that's exactly what we've done
but more specifically why was a package
put together based on 17 games why
wasn't the position taken we're never
going to agree to a package based on 17
games
the leadership never said that we would
never play 17 games in fact the
conference calls the calls the meetings
were always around okay
the league has rejected our 16 game
early proposal they have proposed a 17
game schedule early deal consideration
should we continue to discuss with them
the issues that would go in to such a
proposal if we played 17 games and
ultimately if that's going to be the
proposal on the table that's the one
that's the leadership and and and now
the full membership is going to vote on
okay
you mentioned the concept of it being
the right time as it relates to the TV
contracts there are people who believe
that that that basically if there's a
lot now there will be as much or more
later how do you respond to that that
notion that basically it's just a bluff
or it's it's embellished or it's fake
news or whatever the case may be that
the ball is on the tee or close to it
now for the network's and that ball is
only going to shrink and that pie is
going to shrink if you wait a year or a
year and a half or two years to do a new
CBA yeah I mean Mike you know given
where we are in the country I'm not sure
anybody's quite figured out how to deal
with fake news but I do know how to rely
on data where we look at not only TV
consumption of the NFL but what is
happening with ratings in other sports
and in other television shows the
reality is that the National Football
League product the game that that's
being shown on television is still
extremely popular it's also true that
while viewership has increased over the
last one to two years it's not at its
all-time
so you know part of our my job is it's
certainly as a union leader but we I
spend a lot of time relying on experts
who are making forecasts not only about
television revenue in the future but
also the overall economic outlook for
our business and making determinations
about when is the best time or the
optimal time for the league to do
television contracts and and lastly
factoring into that whether you are at a
position of a net advantage negotiating
with a work stoppage at your back or are
you at a negotiating advantage at a time
when we know that the NFL wants to
strike the most lucrative television
contracts in history so I certainly
understand that people might have a
difference of opinion and certainly
everybody is entitled to their own
opinion I've said it before I'm not sure
anyone is entitled to their own facts so
my job our job is to analyze the facts
that are before us I believe
unequivocally that the that for one of
the rare times in history the interest
of the owners with respect to the TV
contracts and the revenue that's going
to come from those TV contracts is
exactly aligned with that of the players
we constructed a collective bargaining
proposal around those mutual incentives
and here's the reality if if the players
make a decision that they don't want to
do the deal that's fine we go into the
last season this year we'll probably be
facing a work stoppage and for those who
think that that creates an advantage for
the
players they might be right but all of
the indicators that we are with right
now a deal that's on the table that
increases our share by one percent
year-over-year and with the high
potential of increasing it for another
half percent a one and a half percent
change on the table for us as you know
given the revenue in football is
probably the understatement of the year
is that significant if you wanted to
translate that into real dollars it's
anywhere between 2.5 and and perhaps
five billion dollars moving from one
side of the ledger and that that ledger
being in the owners pocket to the
players pocket and that's the deal
that's on the table as well as things
that increase our healthcare increase
our benefits give us more control on our
work schedule and I understand that it
comes with 17th game but that's the deal
that's on the table and I'm proud of the
deal I think that it substantially
increases the benefits to core players
and it's something that I'm happy that
the men in our locker room will get a
chance to vote on okay so for those out
there who are paying attention to this
whether it's fans media players who will
be voting whoever it is that is looking
at this and saying wait how do we know
what are the facts and and I agree with
your statement and I remember from the
last time around you're entitled your
opinion you're not entitled of your
facts what are the facts that you're
relying on that support the idea that
the pie is of a certain size now that a
year from now it will be smaller so if
you get an incremental a larger slice of
the pie your ultimate ly getting less
pie because the TV revenue pie will have
shrunk I think I understand the question
your your your your argument is that if
you wait the pie will shrink
well my question for you is I mean
that's everything I've seen and heard
and read leads me to believe that you've
made the judgment now is the time to
strike to get the optimum slice of pie
from your biggest pie possible and
there's this sense that a year from now
the pie is not going to be as big what
do you say to those who say ah baloney
it'll be just as big if not bigger a
year from now well again I think that
anyone who wants to say that they're
entitled to their opinion the fact that
our incontrovertible right are that the
TV contracts expire in 2022 the the
league would love to renegotiate those
contracts given the media landscape now
that presents them with the greatest
leverage to do that is by walking in
with a deal that has labor peace for the
next ten years but the flip side of it
is also true if we are negotiating at a
point where we are facing a work
stoppage I'm not sure and I'm I don't
really understand you know everything
that everybody has said given you know
their their opposing opinion but there
isn't anything that prevents the league
from going forward and getting TV
contracts without a collective
bargaining agreement I think that if
they have to go and get those TV deals
without long term labor peace it is
common sense that those TV deals will be
less than if they were negotiated with
ten years of labor peace and if those
contracts are indeed less that's a
smaller pie and if the league has to
take a smaller pie why wouldn't they
come back to the players next year and
say there is a smaller pie available
therefore you need and we won't agree to
a larger slice of a smaller pie you
mentioned the TV contracts run through
2022 the monday night football deal as I
understand it actually expires after
2021 which is here before I know it and
I've had people and they raised it as
kind of a hunch kind of an educated
guest is reading the tea leaves do you
know whether or not the league is ready
to move on one or more of these deals
that basically they've got one or more
networks lined up ready to make the
investment ready to commit to some
gigantic checks and they just want to
get this deal done so they can close
those TV deals well I can't tell you
well I can tell you the league doesn't
exactly invite me into those meetings
but it's also shouldn't come to a shock
to anybody that I've met with all the
network's over the last few years so why
don't I just leave it at that
well we talked earlier about the amount
of time that's been put into this and
the meetings and the negotiations
stating dating all the way back to the
the union meeting last March why do you
think there's a perception now that the
players haven't been part of this
process well you know once again I think
that that certainly people are entitled
to their own opinion I know what the
facts are I know what that chronology is
I know and and participated in the
meetings with the board in 2019 with the
conference calls over the long
conference calls over how to craft our
opening proposal the insistence by some
players to get outside consultants to
advise us not only on the twenty eleven
deal but also which should be in the
next deal the vote that
we had on on whether and when to send
out that proposal the meetings that we
had with the owners the meetings that we
had with all 32 teams the conference
calls the negotiations the two player
rep meetings many rep meetings that we
had in Miami during the Superbowl and
then again in Los Angeles after that and
then again in Indianapolis you know Mike
I when I came to this job in 2009 one of
the things that I committed not only
myself to but our staff to was ensuring
that this was going to be a Players
Union and you know I made the decision
to recommend adding former players to
our Executive Committee it was I'm glad
that the reps you know took my
recommendation to increase the number of
player representatives per team to
invite players even who weren't reps to
come to rep meeting I'm proud of our
history of transparency and and an
inclusion and given those facts I'm
never going to give credence to to any
opinion that somehow people have been
frozen out of this process social media
was around in 2011 the last time we went
through this but it wasn't developed to
the point where it now is for better or
for worse what's been your perception on
the role of social media the comments
from players the back-and-forth does
that help the process does it hurt the
process and how much do you follow up
with players when you see that they're
expressing their views on social media
you know I never really talked about you
know my personal conversations with
players so I'm gonna how about if I skip
the last one you know I think you know a
person like you and and and maybe some
time after this
love to you know grab a beer with you I
think I would love to get your views on
the question that that you asked about
the impact of social media you know I
think whether we are looking at a
campaign that's going on or a Democratic
primary that's going on right now and
the effect of social media look at the
way the coronavirus has been covered in
social media does it have an impact on
the process I think only a fool would
say that it does not I think to a
certain extent the the advent of instant
communication is for the most part a
good thing I think that it gives people
a voice at the same time it gives people
a voice and I do think that going
forward this is a paradigm that we have
now found ourselves in whether it's it's
politics or the economy or healthcare or
collective bargaining agreements I think
that there is a paradigm that we all now
find ourselves living in and in some
respects grappling with but here's what
I you know my touchstone is this
I'm constitutionally bound and I've got
a fiduciary duty as a union leader to
serve the interest of our players there
is never going to be a night that I put
my head down on my pillow where I
haven't thought that I've done that and
you know sometimes you know whether it's
team visits or long telephone calls or
being away from my family or you know
spending time teaching educating it's
not just me we have a team of people who
have dedicated themselves to making sure
that this is a union where our players
are involved and and like I said you
know people may not always agree but you
know the one thing we certainly have in
this union and and I'm proud of it are
group of people who are passionate about
their union certainly not afraid to
express their opinion I'm not sure
anybody out there is going to take a
position that somehow we we stifle a
comment or communication or expressions
of opinion in this union that's fine
I'll take that any day of the week then
than to be in a position where we don't
know where our players stand or we don't
have the ability to communicate with
them instantly but when you see on
social media D some opinions negative
opinions about the deal from
high-profile players without a lot of
detail JJ Watt heart note no explanation
Russell Wilson very limited explanation
other players express their views
Marquis Pouncy amid the profanity no
without a whole lot of explanation
without getting into what you talked
about with him do you talk to them do
you reach out to them to find out
exactly what their their basis for
objecting to the CBA is you know Mike I
guess your desire to get me to talk
about any conversation no I'm just
saying I'm saying from this is curiosity
from my perspective D when you see these
tweets coming from guys who aren't
involved in union leadership they're not
members of the board of player rep
they're not members of the Executive
Committee they've had no role in the
negotiations and they do a drive-by no
III mean what do you do do you talk to
them do you try to find out what they're
talking about I'm I don't want you to
get into conversations
I'm just curious whether you just shrug
out it like I do whether you that you
know that that that between the Union
myself our staff we we maintain contact
with all of our players and Mike I would
say whether a guy is on the board of
reps and some of these guys are or
whether they're a part of the executive
committee and some of these guys are
or whether they've not been a part of it
there
they're more than entitled to express
their thought in their opinion and and
we certainly continue to maintain
contact with them I just draw a hard
line because I do think that that while
there is certainly a entertainment value
to to finding out what my conversations
might be with someone I'm always going
to respect the confidentiality of the
conversations that I have with the
players but you can rest assured that
there is always two-way communication
and I can certainly tell you from the
players that I've talked to
I doubt that there's many players in the
National Football League who don't have
my cell phone they've certainly blown it
up when they've wanted to and and that's
a good thing and I will take issue with
your suggestion that there's
entertainment value I can show you the
traffic to our CBA related stories
there's a whole lot of entertainment
being generated because you know you've
got guys who are saying no and I'd be
curious to know why they say no and
they're not telling us maybe they're
telling you but I respected that you
choose to keep those conversations
private all right let's spin this
forward a little bit if your vote is no
next week when they do the final tally
independent auditor fails to get 50%
plus one of those who vote what happens
next well then we you know I hate to
sound like a patriot slogan but it's on
to the 2020 season you know the the
league took two votes the league
approved the the proposal that was on
the table they also took a second vote
to say that they would go through the
2020 season and go through expiration
the practical ramifications of that is
that all of the
improvements to the collective
bargaining agreement on salary benefits
work schedule commissioner discipline
offseason all of those things that would
go into the 2020 season would not go
into the 2020 season and that would
include significant increases in the
salary of the majority of our players it
would mean that the the current deal is
is no longer on the table and we would
go into the 2020 season if the league
decided to negotiate they would the
players would have to decide whether or
not they wanted to make an overture to
the owners to engage in collective
bargaining the owners could say that
they want to do that they could say that
they don't want to do that but they took
a vote to go through exploration and and
I would assume that that's what they
would do and we would be facing either a
negotiation in late 2021 or a work
stoppage a strike or a lockout in 2021
or the league could you know as you know
and I'm sure your your your the people
who are you know following every second
of this know what imposition is but you
know from a lawyer standpoint that the
league could also impose a system and
they could impose a system of how many
games pay salary benefits and they could
impose that system and and it would
probably be a system that's worse than
the system that we're working under now
and they would basically dare the
players to strike under that system so
you know nobody has a crystal ball but
that those things are probably the
likely scenario in the event of a no
vote and I want to make sure folks
understand this because they believe it
very binary once the contract expires
it's either a lockout or a strike there
is an opportunity by management this is
a standard principle of labor law to
impose the last best offer before an
impasse has reached at the bargaining
table and that last best offer could
indeed be worse than the offer that's on
the table today we won't know until we
get there absolutely correct and in the
history of the National Football League
the players actually played under an
imposed system you know several decades
ago and and you know if you remember the
Plan B system but that was an imposed
system that was a restraint on trade it
was it was not a good system for the
players but that was an imposed system
and and they imposed that system
you know after I'm sorry before you know
strikes that were were not successful
but you know you know Mike in 2017 I
told our guys to be ready for a work
stoppage I told them that they needed to
start saving their money they needed to
drastically reduce their debt we had a
work stoppage manual sent out to every
player and every agent several months
ago
it included ways to change their
mortgage to a union plus mortgage where
if there was a work stoppage there could
be loan forgiveness so the good news is
since the players knew about the
possibility of a work stoppage in 2017
and so did the agents by the time we get
to 2021 every player should know whether
they are prepared for a long term work
stop but you're not as it relates to the
NFL and this is something that I've been
kicking around lately as it relates to a
work stoppage actually being something
that can last we saw the strike in 1987
it was three or four weeks before
players started across the picket line
in return after the replacement players
were put in place the lockout ended last
time around just on the cusp of players
actually losing real money and the
ability to play why is it in your
estimation D that it's harder for NFL
players to hold firm in a work stoppage
whether it's a lockout or a strike I'm
not going to make any predictions about
the future because I do think that one
change is a we started preparing for
this in 2017 so my hope is that a work
stoppage with that many years of
preparation it would have a better
outcome then then the work stoppages I'm
sorry the strikes in the past but you
know when you look at work stoppages you
don't have to just look at football
hockey went through a lockout you know
almost on the cusp of the lockout by the
NFL in 2011 they went through their
lockout at I think 2004 2005 for a
general question of why work stoppages
have been tough in the sports context I
really don't have a good answer and I
don't want to sound you know trite but
when you do have a group of athletes who
are compensated at a higher rate than
average Americans and and they do have
shorter careers and that might factor
into the willingness to sacrifice you
know whether if it's a you know in our
case the players are playing an average
of three three and a half years a work
stoppage of a year is one-third of of
the earnings to put a number on it's
probably six north of six billion
dollars in salary a year but the flip
side of it is you do see successful
straw
when it comes to teachers autoworkers
dollar store employees and those are
people who for the most part are living
paycheck to paycheck so when I say that
IIIi don't know or understand you know I
I'm a student and I'm a proud member of
the labor movement strikes by ordinary
working people throughout history are
always tough and they always envisioned
a tremendous amount of sacrifice and if
you look at teachers and and others who
have gone on strike in the last two or
three years you know I think you'd agree
with me it's mostly teachers and and
other low you know lower wage earners
who are really bringing back the
strength of the labor movement the
reality is all of those people who are
going on strikes are really putting at
risk the day to day living expenses for
their families so you know my hope that
is that if that the players took the
work stoppage advice from 2017 to heart
my hope is that starting soon after 2017
that they have been working with their
agents to reduce their debt and to
certainly have a savings account with
you know multiple zeroes in it prepared
for them heading into into next year and
if they've done that then then we will
be in a position of strength do you know
whether they have do you keep track of
that or is it just something that's
impossible to monitor it's something
that's impossible to monitor because I
look I am always going to rely on the
word of our players you know last week
ESPN you know completely
turday headline saying that i was
confident that this deal would pass
actually what I said was that I remain
confident in our players and in their
families and that's never changed so you
know I'm not going to ask people to
turnover bank accounts we certainly stay
in touch with the agents and I had a
good discussion with the agent community
both in Indianapolis and we met with the
agents during during Super Bowl and you
know certainly they are closer to the
financial preparation of the players for
a work stoppage that's why I believe
having a good relationship with them is
so important but other than relying on
what I'm hearing from agents and the
information that we have relentlessly
provided to our players we have to hope
for the best
historically during your tenure as
executive director it seems like the
relationship with agents has been not
great why do you think there's been some
acrimony some mistrust whatever the
right words would be it hasn't been
harmonious at times why do you think
that is you know my guy I am I will
certainly take the blame for creating
and having high expectations for
everyone in this business and and that
goes not only to our men where I
challenge them to take leadership
responsibilities challenge them to make
decisions on their own I'm not going to
spoon-feed you answers I'm not going to
tell you what to do your job as a man of
businessmen and the business of football
is to understand exactly what what your
role is and and to have accountability
for it if I'm going to take that
position with our own players I'm
certainly going to take that
position with financial advisors agents
coaches general managers and owners of
the National Football League and I'm not
sure that that means that I should be
you know blamed for it but I'm happy to
take the blame for taking a position
that where people have accountability
where people have responsibility and
where people have a financial duty that
it is the job of the Union in those
circumstances to hold those people
accountable and I get that I probably am
NOT the most I think I've said it to
someone else I'm not a hugger um that's
that's the business whether you know the
time that I was a prosecutor or the time
that I was at at the law firm that's not
the environment that I grew up in I've
always been comfortable with people
telling me exactly what's expected of me
and and holding me accountable to it and
if that causes acrimony or a lack of
warm and fuzzy I get it but I had I
think what I would you know
characterizes a great meeting with the
agents in Indianapolis I think that in
the same way that you and I talked about
social media as it affects you know
politics or this process I think social
media has an impact on how people are
viewed and so be it
but I'm never going to apologize for the
role of this Union and holding people
accountable to a group of players who
take pride in what they do and and
literally rely on the advice that
they're going to be getting from their
agent from their financial adviser and I
know not everybody has been happy with
the rules and regulations that we've
imposed or certainly the demands that
we've put on can
canoeing education or making sure that
our our membership understands fees and
and what fees are for and what they're
not for but you know Mike you know we
sometimes you know people have tough
jobs and they the players who elected me
elected me to adhere to strict standards
of of what I am supposed to do and I
actually enjoy doing it and I don't go
out of my way to rub people the wrong
way okay maybe I do sometimes well that
we have that in common we have several
things in common but that's definitely
one of them specific questions about the
actual nuts and bolts of the deal but
something you said earlier and then you
you've added some fuel to the fire by
pointing out your past as a prosecutor
and as a lawyer it's it's a true law
nerd question for you here we go here we
go hypothetical let's say we get to the
end of the contract the NFL imposes last
best offer new set of rules like they
did years ago and the Union does what it
did years ago disclaim interest
decertify whatever the right word is and
therefore the NFL is no longer protected
by the antitrust exemption that comes
from the union relationship and the
players while working and getting paid
pursuant to the imposed rules by
ownership decide to sue the NFL for
every possible antitrust violation from
salary cap to franchise tag to the draft
everything that would be a restraint of
trade exacerbated by the American Needle
case from a decade ago why not just do
that
that seems like that would be the
ultimate way to squeeze the league
because you gonna have your cake and eat
it too
your guys keep working they keep getting
paid and you can challenge everything
they do collectively as an antitrust
violation you know as a nerdy lawyer and
someone who who prides himself on on
game strategy that is certainly a a game
option the only thing that that I would
say
is you know every game and I don't mean
this in a in a trite sense but but every
scenario let's say while feasible has
downsides right the first downside of a
living under imposed system is let's
just we could put you and I could
probably agree that the imposed system
is not going to be forty seven or forty
seven and a half percent of revenue
right I mean I would I would I would
agree with that if we consider the deals
get delayed with T V by a year yeah I
mean they can make whatever number they
want at that point correct so they could
they would probably certainly decide to
pay us less that's number one there
would probably be the elimination of
benefits that would be - it might be a
16-game schedule it might be a 17-game
schedule that's that's fine but their
win 18-game schedule could be an 18-game
standing there could be but there there
certainly would be a scenario where it
would be less than the economic package
and the benefits package and the work
rules package that is on the table now
that's number one number two while you
know you and I you know would certainly
love the opportunity that get back into
a courtroom we would always advise our
clients that that antitrust lawsuit
would begin on day one and that lawsuit
would probably not see would probably
not make its way before a jury for at
least two years and that even after you
started that lawsuit after two years
that you would have to win it and and I
think you know I'm not saying I'm not
expressing confidence in my ability as a
lawyer at least not right now but given
the restraint on trades and
state of the law there is a high
likelihood that that we would prevail
simply because the law is on our side
but you and I would have to advise our
client about what the appellate process
right
which probably adds at least
conservatively what would you say a year
or another two years 18 months minimum
minimum so now we're at two years plus
18 months of an appeals process and that
is before you have earned I'm sorry that
is before one single dollar has been
paid to a player so if you and I are at
least conservative about the timing of
that scenario you are talking about a
generation of players because it's a
four year timespan who will have played
for less probably played for less
benefits the first thing that if I were
the league that I would certainly get
rid of is the pension because almost no
corporation in America has a defined
benefit plan anymore
so the win after four years the win
would be that there would be dollars
paid to players who are no longer
playing and it might result in in
renewed interest in in collective
bargaining but I think what some people
forget is even after that imposed system
lawsuit antitrust law remedies appellate
process even the paying of damages the
next step for the players and the owners
would be what collective bargaining
right right right
so you would ultimately end up starting
a process that we just finished and look
that might be a battle that we have
to fight and and it might be the opinion
of others that that's somehow better and
and they're welcome to it but the fact
is that that antitrust litigation
strategy ends with the very same
collective bargaining that we just went
through okay a couple of specific topics
under the CBA if you still have some
more time I've imposed on you for 45
minutes now but I want to be able to
quickly if we can all right marijuana
policy revolutionary changes no
suspensions for positive tests under any
of the substances of abuse separate
apart from PE D obviously but for the
street drugs no more suspensions for
positive tests the limits raised for
marijuana from thirty five nanograms one
hundred and fifty why not just get rid
of the marijuana testing all together
given the extent to which these changes
have been made yes and we proposed that
the other thing you didn't mention was
that the testing window which I think
now is I think it is actually April 20th
yes it is more 20 or not it is 4/20
I'm sure that's coincidence but the
testing window that's now it's at April
20th through training camp that testing
window drops dramatically to simply two
weeks we proposed eliminating it
altogether we ended up with a policy
that includes all the things that you
said and the narrowest testing window
that we could have that's where we ended
up and now under the new policy you can
only get that banishment for a minimum
of one year if you fail to cooperate
with testing or fail to comply with your
clinical treatment procedure at least I
think it's four times maybe seven no
it's seven times it's four times before
you're suspended it's seven times before
we get to banishment what happens to the
guys who were banished under the old
policy the Josh Gordon's martavis Bryant
do they immediately get reinstated or do
they have to go through the process like
they would under the old CBA
well you're talking about players who
are no longer in the league guys who are
serving suspensions under the former CBA
if the new ones put in place and they
were suspended because of positive tests
and now there's no suspensions for
positive tests what happened to them
right we'll have to take a look at that
issue but to your point I just want to
make sure that we were clear on the
changes between suspensions and
banishment what we tried to do with the
policy was to narrow the the testing
window to us as small as possible which
means necessarily that after that
testing window ends
no one's testing for marijuana if that
makes sense I'm sorry
oh you mean yeah after the testing
window ends no one's testing for
marijuana but but if you're in the
program you're being tested for
marijuana in that and while you're in
the program the idea is to be far more
therapeutic than punitive so there's an
assessment about whether or not there
are any other issues but after that to
your point there we virtually eliminated
the the the the punitive nature of
marijuana the the 2006 contract it had
an opt-out in it for both sides in the
NFL took advantage of that in 2008
setting the stage for the lockout in
2011 one question I've seen people raise
why isn't there a provision in this deal
that extends roughly a decade to opt out
for either side at some point three
years five years six years in yep and
look one of the main lessons that I took
coming into this job is it was to study
the impact of the league having an
opt-out of the 2006 contract you hit the
nail on his head the
League negotiated and agreed to a
contract in 2006 they were happy with
that contract for a grand total of I
think 18 months when they opted out in
2008 they opted out primarily because
they forecast and and then went through
a huge economic downturn in 2008 and
they utilized their opt-out provision
remember the players did not want to opt
out in 2008 the owners utilize their
opt-out provision in 2008 because they
wanted to take advantage of the fact
that there was an economic downturn they
didn't like the way that they were stuck
on the debt service to their stadiums
and they opted out of a contract in 2008
to take money away from the players so
fast forwarding to 2011 we signed a deal
with no opt-out but you and I both know
that there was a downturn in television
ratings nearly midway through that deal
right I think 2016 2017 yes if you were
the league in 2016 2017 and you saw an X
I'm sorry you saw a which started to be
a sharp decline in viewership of TV of
your game in 2016 and 2017
would you have opted out of this
contract in 2011 if I was their lawyer I
would have recommended they do that I
believe that would have been a serious
detriment to the players because for the
last ten years eight years we have seen
a salary cap that has grown by at least
ten million dollars in some cases I'm
sorry
ten yeah ten million dollars per Club
over the last eight years if the owners
could have opted out of that deal in
2016 that would have been a net
detriment to the players right
I mean the same thing is sort of the
same analysis going forward and again
people can have their opinions about
what's going to happen in the future but
if Tamir the economics of the last deal
if we know conservatively that a one to
one and a half point change means a
shift of money from the owners to the
players in billions of dollars do we
make a judgment that that's in the best
interest of players without an opt-out
yes
does it insulate the players against a
potential downturn in television revenue
yes did we change the way in which we
monitor and improve the amount of
revenue coming into the business of
football to ensure that players get
their share yes were we able at a
position right now to forecast the
changes in the gambling laws and to
create language that ensured that the
majority of gambling related revenue
both on football and in some cases non
football gambling comes into the coffers
of the players yes were we able to make
sure that changes in intellectual
property down the road where the law you
and I both know that the law on
intellectual property for consumers
isn't particularly good the players have
a much better intellectual property
protection and data preservation and
ownership protection than the average
citizens do under the law so anytime
you're making a decision about whether
the things you can write up are more
likely to be better over a longer period
of time as long as the other side can't
opt out that became the consensus of
not only are inside lawyers but are
outside lawyers and and the myriad of
consultants that we rely on to make sure
that we're getting the answers at least
as we know is as good as right as
possible so and see that I'm sorry that
was a long answer but that's why no no
we chose no opt out as you explained it
though it dawned on me that this is the
crux of the problem deep on one hand
this needs to be a partnership between
the NFL and the players and it needs to
feel like a partnership that has
cooperation minimal fighting everybody
trying to help each other the rising
tide lifts all boats etcetera etcetera
but on the other hand it's a union
arrangement where there is a certain
amount of built-in baked-in hostility it
has to be there because both sides are
watching each other and and I feel like
we're at a point in the development of
this industry where the pendulum may be
swinging more toward this idea that
really is a partnership which makes it a
little more complicated for a union to
work the way it's supposed to because
you don't want to be fighting all the
time with your partner you want to be a
good partner does that make any sense at
all to you a little bit but you know you
know me and and you certainly have known
the history over the last 10 years I
mean we are a partnership but you know
the last 10 years of quote-unquote labor
peace haven't been that peaceful and if
and if the time comes where we have to
do our job to protect our players and
that means whether it's suing the
National Football League
like we've like we've done suing them
not only over the personal conduct
policy but suing them over over issues
of revenue that we thought was coming
our way
we've won most of those lawsuits am I
happy about it you know sure am i
thrilled that we had to fight over it no
none of that is going to change but to
your point and I think maybe this is
what you
were alluding to does that mean that
where we are right now was a rare moment
in time given the changing revenue
giving given the change in the TV
landscape given what what we're
forecasting are the economic headwinds
that we may be facing and realizing that
a tremendous amount of revenue is coming
off of their plate onto our plate by a
change in the percentages is this one of
those rare times in history where many
of our interests are aligned and the
answer is yes and that is why both sides
work to get a deal done and am i
positive that there are some things that
the owners wish that they haven't given
up on sure did we get everything that we
wanted no but given that alignment to
recognize and reap the benefits of an
early deal it did provide our players
with one thing that we can all agree on
a democratic process where they get to
vote on whether they're going to accept
an early deal or not and if they vote
YES that's great
a lot of great things improve for
players if they vote no that's the
democracy and we play next year and we
we proceed forth with whatever our fate
is and with all that said you said
earlier that you're proud of the deal do
you make a recommendation to the rank
and file as to whether or not they
should accept it you know what I kind of
view my role more as a teacher and I lay
out for our players as best I can
explaining what's on the table
certainly explaining leverage and and
the importance of where we are right now
and and whether that provides us with
leverage
and an opportunity with wiz Management
it's also my job to teach them about
leverage or the absence of it or the
presence of it if you're facing a work
stoppage you know we have a few guys who
went through the lockout and I rely on
them to talk about what it's like to go
through a work stoppage
it's my job to teach them about the
history of work stoppages not only in
our profession but in other sports
professions but mine you know if you ask
any player whether they've heard about
the Triangle Shirtwaist Factory fire or
the fact that teachers have been going
on strikes or the fact that I walked to
picket lines while we were in Miami and
the importance of solidarity and the
willing the willingness to sacrifice
things for for generations to come
they hear all of that do I you know
ultimately tell them you know which way
do I think it finally tips yes but only
after I believe is my obligation to lay
out and to teach facts and and after
that you know people can can disagree
and again they can have their opinion
but when it comes to the fact that's
really where I focus my team meetings
and and and individual conversations I
have with players well Dee this has been
very helpful to me it's a full hour I'm
not gonna impose on your time anymore I
know I'm taking the rest of the day off
you probably will not be so good good
luck as this process continues and
appreciate your time in explaining this
to our audience whoever may be in it
whoever may be interested this was an
opportunity to hear it straight from the
guy who negotiated the deal along with
the NFLPA Executive Committee he's
executive director - demora Smith and
Dee we hope to talk to you again down
the road Mike thank you
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports